le confinement a commencé mardi 17 mars
comment ça se passe pour vous alors moi
je travaillais mon mari et du poil en
chômage partiel donc pour l'instant
c'est lui qui s'occupe de notre fils
mais bon c'est avec on a une terrasse
par chance donc c'est un peu plus facile
à livre vu qu'en plus en ce moment il
fait beau du coup bas au moins le petit
peut profiter un petit peu de la
terrasse vous dites que vous travaillez
comment ça se passe au travail ça va on
a des mesures de protection qu'un masque
et balance nettoie les mains tout le
temps à chaque passage de clients mais
ça va ça va les clients sont
relativement compréhensif donc ça va
psychologiquement à voir ce confinement
que comment vous le vivez en fait c'est
c'est assez difficile mais je pense que
de toute façon il faut tout ce qu'on
respecte pas les mesures pour que ça se
dissipe de plus en plus en plus pour ma
part ma maman et dans le monde
hospitalier donc je pense principalement
à l
et voilà je pense que c'est très dur
pour le personnel soignant donc il
faudrait au maximum le respecter et
c'est comme ça incite à ne durer qu'un
jour ça sera 15 jours et plus ça sera
plus c'est que c'est que temporaire donc
un jour ou l'autre de toute façon
pouvoir sortir de la maison
vous vivez au village à elancourt et
vous avez lancé un appel sur les réseaux
sociaux est ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer votre démarche
et pourquoi vous avez lancé cet appel
oui alors j'ai lancé un appel s'il y
avait des personnes en situation de
handicap peut vous même sans permis ou
des personnes âgées
quitte à aller faire les courses et
peut-être faire la queue ou quoi que ce
soit il ya les justes pour moi où il ya
les pour moi et plusieurs personnes
ça change rien du tout donc j'ai lancé
un appel sur le groupe facebook tu sais
que tu viens d'elancourt et voilà je les
fais juste comme ça par solidarité parce
que j'ai des grands-parents et
j'aimerais bien que quelqu'un les aide
un petit peu donc à mon niveau essayer
d'aider les gens qui sont plutôt proches
de moi vu que ils sont un peu plus loin
c'est des téléspectateurs il encourt toi
ne nous écoute
comment peuvent-ils prendre contact avec
vous alors ils peuvent prendre contact
avec moi directement sur mon facebook
donc c'est morgane watteau w à dte à vue
ou directement par mail et c'est pareil
c'est morgane points watteau @ gmail
point com et comment vous allez vous
organiser parce qu'il ya des gestes
barrières à respecter donc comment vous
pouvez faire les courses pour d'autres
personnes
ah ben je ferai les courses et je
déposerai directement les sachets devant
la porte
on n'aura pas de contacts rien du tout
et voilà à savoir je crois que le virus
reste plusieurs heures sur les paquets
donc il faudra juste attendre un tout
petit peu avant de les prendre mais on
se mettra pas du tout en contact merci
et morgane watteau pour votre témoignage
de rien merci à vous et puis bon courage
pour cette période exceptionnelle est
difficile merci voici un bon courage